like many others Hina beam came to
protest about missing family members but
the human change their form was quickly
dispersed by police her son a member of
a student opposition group was detained
by plain clothes officer 10 years
ago we are citizens of Bangladesh and
have the right to protest anywhere why
is my son still missing and why am I not
able to talk about him without any
harassment what crime have we
done Bangladeshi human rights monitor
says Security forces have carried out
more than 600 enforced disappearance
since
2009 human rights violations are now at
their extreme and we have seen this sort
of repression and Crackdown before every
elections for the last 15 years critics
of the government say a Crackdown on the
opposition is creating a climate of fear
ahead of parliamentary elections due on
January the 7th in recent weeks many
members of opposition have gone into
hiding fearing arbitrary arrest or
enforced disappearance Lion's father a
local politician was taken by plain
cloth's policemen before the 2014
election it's been a decade and I still
don't know where my father is we want
all those who are still illegally
detained in secret cells to be
immediately released the government says
it's creating a conducive environment
for the elections but analysts and
rights groups say State authorities are
simultaneously filling prisons with
opposition party members Chan chadri Al
jazer
Daka make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer